Just having read,
having heard a bit of Satan tonight and
having read a bit of Macbeth,
that there's a thing when you play a
Baddie in Shakespeare where you can be
sympathetic,
you can be,
you know,
we have Patrick Stewart playing a
sympathetic child murderer in the west
end on the same day that we feel our
front pages of the tabloids with
terrible things about child murder.
It's a very odd,
I'm a coexistence,
but you,
you have to leap the tragedy.
Train at some point as an audience,
as it careers towards the,
the bloody buffers.
You have to lose sympathy for him,
however much he carries you along
because he's going to be damned.
That doesn't happen with Satan because
he's not human.
What's the worst thing that can happen
too?
It's already happened.
And so Milton,
it struck me tonight,
has done a sort of extraordinarily
extraordinary high jump imaginatively
and morally.
He's,
he's given you this person who has all
the best shoes.
I've given you sympathy for the devil.
Um,
which is also a great team.
Uh Huh.
And then he sort of made it impossible
for you to withdraw your sympathy from
him because he's so clearly having a
worse time than you are.
And I'm not sure Shakespeare never quite
does that.
Um,
and I just wanted to say that I think
it's,
um,
it gives you quite a sort of vertigo,
morally,
and that's extraordinary.